hey schön dass ihr dabei seid zdf heute
live eigentlich wollten wir mit euch
erst in einer halben stunde live gehen
denn der bundeskanzler scholz ist heute
in moskau beim russischen präsidenten
putin und die pressekonferenz zu der wir
live schalten wollen gleich die war für
16 uhr angesetzt die läuft jetzt aber
schon wir gehen mit euch live und danach
ganz in ruhe gibt es von uns die
einschätzung wir schalten rüber aber
wir sind der meinung dass all diese
probleme in complex komplex betrachtet
werden müssen ohne ohne im zusammenhang
der internet von interessen russlands
natürlich ist die europäische
sicherheits thematik wurde innerhalb der
themen um
europäischen konflikt wie er wir wissen
verweigerte ukrainische seite die
verhandlungen 2014
und auch in späteren späten späteren
enorm anti format erreichten
vereinbarungen einzuhalten
verfassungsreform nächsten
kommunalwahlen rechtliche
besonderen status von dem was sind nicht
geklärt werden
ebenfalls ist die formel des ehemaligen
außenministers und heutigen
bundespräsidenten steinmeier jahren
nicht implementiert worden das wurde
damals vom tanz stand maier vorgestellt
als kompromiss um die
schlüssel der wichtigen richtung zu
fahren all das wurde noch nicht
implementiert
nach wie vor werden die
werden die möglichkeiten zur
wiederherstellung oder
indirekt
die diskriminierung der russischen der
russischen bevölkerung wird unmittelbar
ausgefüllt wir haben auch andere
internationale probleme es ging um den
iranischen nuklearprogramm saßen unter
außenministerium kontaktiert ständig
also es war auf dem laufenden in diesem
zusammenhang und wir müssen zugeben dass
unsere position in gerade in diesem
punkt sehen da niemand möchte ein und
das ganze ja ganz herzlich danken für
die zusammenarbeit für den nutzen für
den musischen und inhaltsreichen dialog
fehlen dann für ihre aufmerksamkeit
meine damen und herren ist es gut und
wichtig heute hier in moskau zu sein
bedanke mich für den empfang und für das
lange ausführliche gespräch wir haben
bisher schon der darstellung des
präsidenten entnommen haben kein thema
ausgelassen das gegenwärtig in den
beziehungen zwischen unseren beiden
ländern aber auch in den europäischen
beziehungen internationalen beziehungen
eine rolle spielt das ist gut so denn
natürlich es ist wichtig dass wir
tatsächlich miteinander wegen unsere
beiden länder sind historisch und
kulturell eng miteinander verflochten
die beziehungen sind tief und vielfältig
das zeigen beispielsweise die mehr als
90 aktiven städtepartnerschaften und der
regel kultur jugend und
bildungsaustausch da da ist das
deutschlandjahr in russland zu ende
gegangen etwa 1000 veranstaltungen in
mehr als 70 städten behandelten das
ganze themenspektrum unserer beziehung
von kultur über wissenschaft umwelt und
nachhaltigkeit bis zur diversität
auch unsere wirtschaftsbeziehungen haben
nach wie vor großes potenzial das haben
sie ihn schon gehört insbesondere war
zentralen zukunftsthemen wie der
dekarbonisierung bei den erneuerbaren
energien bei wasserstoff und der
digitalisierung
unsere verantwortung für das
menschheitsthema klimawandel können wir
nur gerecht werden wenn wir das
gemeinsam angehen und deshalb ist es
wichtig dass auch in den beziehungen
zwischen deutschland und russland das
für die zukunft von zentraler bedeutung
bleibt energie wird heute auch geliefert
aber die frage ist wie wir es
hinbekommen dass das auch gelingen kann
in einer industriellen welt die co2
neutral ist was notwendig ist wenn wir
auf diesem planeten gut leben können
wollen ein unverzichtbarer pfeiler
unserer beziehung ist er zwischen
gesellschaftlicher dialog der viel zur
verständigung zur aussöhnung zwischen
unseren völkern nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg beigetragen hat diese
entwicklung gilt es weiter zu fördern
darum wollen wir heute auch schon über
dem petersburger dialog gesprochen er
steht seit jahren für die
deutsch-russische verständigung ist
gerade jetzt wichtiger denn wie ich habe
daher meine hoffnung zum ausdruck
gebracht dass bei weiteren hochrangigen
gesprächen in nächster zeit eine lösung
für die aktuelle blockade erreicht
werden kann und wir brauchen einen raum
für offenen und ehrlichen dialog bei dem
alle themen besprochen werden können und
auch alle sich in diese debatte
einbringen können die das wollen und die
dazu gehören mit sorge sehen wir wie die
räume für die zivilgesellschaft
schwieriger werden das gilt für uns
insbesondere im hinblick auf solche
partner mit denen belange und wichtig
zusammengearbeitet haben ich will hier
die gruppe memorial nennen dass es in
deutschland auf großes unverständnis
gestoßen
dass die ihre tätigkeit nur nicht
fortsetzen kann ausgerechnet eine
organisation die unter anderem einen
zentralen beitrag zur aufklärung des
schicksals der sowjetischen
zwangsarbeiter im nazi deutschland
geleistet hat wir hoffen dass dort eine
gute perspektive möglich ist ich habe in
unseren gesprächen auch die erwartung
geäußert dass die deutsche welle in
russland weiter journalistisch tätig
sein kann wie schon gesagt ein breites
themenspektrum von bilateralen interesse
und wir haben dabei auch die kritischen
fragen nicht vermieden das zeichnet
solche gespräche aus und ist wichtig
mein besuch heute gesteht aber natürlich
ganz wesentlich im zeichen der krise der
wohl schwersten bedrohlichsten krise die
wir seit sehr langer zeit in europa
jetzt erleben die
militärischen
truppen zusammenstellung und aktivitäten
russlands an der ukrainischen grenze
haben einen breiten raum in unseren
gesprächen gibt eingenommen wie auch
natürlich die frage nach den
sicherheitsgarantien die russland
formuliert hat ich habe dabei unsere
einschätzung meiner einschätzung der
sicherheitslage erläutert und wie wir
unsere europäischen partner diese
entwicklung bewerten aber auch natürlich
den truppenaufmarsch
als bedrohung empfinden in diesem
zusammenhang kann man gar nicht genug
betonen dass wir sehr besorgt sind was
wohl aus dem mit 100.000 soldaten und
den aktivitäten der minister zeigt
werden wird die können keinen
vernünftigen grund für diese truppen
zusammenstellung erkennen deshalb ist
die deeskalation dringend geboten und
das ist in dieser angestellten und
schwierigen situation wichtig damit es
keinen krieg in europa gibt
präsident putin hat mir in unserem
gespräch von den gestrigen beratungen
mit seinem außenminister und dem
verteidigungsminister berichtet hat eben
davon auch erneut gesprochen stimme
ausdrücklich zu die diplomatischen
möglichkeiten sind bei weitem nicht
ausgeschöpft jetzt muss es darum gehen
entschlossen mutig an einer friedlichen
auflösung dieser krise zu arbeiten
dass wir jetzt hören dass einzelne
truppen abgezogen werden ist jedenfalls
ein gutes zeichen
wir hoffen dass dann noch welche folgen
wir sind bereit gemeinsam mit allen
partnern und verbündeten in der eu und
der nato und russland über ganz konkrete
schritte zur verbesserung der
gegenseitigen oder noch besser der
gemeinsamen sicherheit zu unternehmen
dazu hat die nato bereits zu konkreten
thematischen gespräch im
nato-russland-rat eingeladen dazu sind
die usa in den bilateralen gesprächen
mit russland bereit und im rahmen auch
der osze hat der polnischen vorsitz an
neuen hochrangigen dialog prozess
initiiert
dieser dialog wird im geist der
gegenseitigkeit und in anerkennung der
gesamtheit von prinzipien und
verpflichtungen erfolgen wie wir sie
alle gemeinsam in der osze vereinbart
haben dazu gehören die unverletzlichkeit
der grenzen europa und die souveränität
und territoriale unversehrtheit aller
staaten auch der ukraine und die sind
für uns und verhandelbar
ein dringender wunsch
lassen sie uns diese dinge im wege des
dialogs weiter wir reden wir dürfen
nicht in einer sackgasse enden die wäre
ein unglück für uns alle
für die bundesregierung ist klar dass
eine weitere militärische aggression
gegen die ukraine
schwerwiegende politische
wirtschaftliche und strategische
konsequenzen zur folge hätte mein
eindruck ist dass wissen alle ganz genau
eine solche eskalation gilt es deshalb
jetzt mit aller kraft und
entschlossenheit und aller klugheit zu
vermeiden die suche nach diplomatischen
lösungen sind ein zentraler grund meiner
reise nach kiew gestern und nach moskau
präsident putin und ich sind uns einig
dass das normandie format neben den
gesprächen zwischen den usa und russland
im nato-russland-rat und der osze ein
weiteres wichtiges format zur beilegung
des konflikts darstellt hier brauchen
wir bewegung und natürlich auch
fortschritt
deshalb ist es gut dass präsident
selensky gestern fest zugesagt hat
dass der trilateralen kontaktgruppe die
im rahmen des minsker prozess
festgesetzt worden ist und der alle
beteiligten zusammen kommen in kürze
alle drei vorgesehenen gesetzestext zum
status der ost ukraine zur
verfassungsänderung zur wahlvorbereitung
vorliegen werden das ist ein guter
fortschritt und daran gilt es
anzuknüpfen
ich habe dem präsidenten am und hat
seine verhandlung mit einem
entsprechenden konstruktiven mandat aus
zu gestalten so dass wir dort
fortschritte erreichen kann
zum abschluss auch noch mal dies für uns
deutsche
aber auch für alle europäer ist klar
dass nachhaltige sicherheit nicht gegen
russland und nur mist russland erreicht
werden kann darüber sind wir uns aber
auch alle einig in der nato und in der
europäischen union und deshalb müsse es
möglich sein eine lösung zu finden zu
schwierig und ernst die derzeitige lage
auch scheint ich weigere mich sie als
aussichtslos zu beschreiben
von allen ist jetzt mutiges und
verantwortungsbewusstes handeln gefragt
das will ich doch sagen für meine
generation ist krieg in europa und
denkbar geworden und wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass das so bleibt es ist unsere
verdammte pflicht und aufgabe als staats
und regierungschefs zu verhindern dass
es in europa zu einer kriegerischen
eskalation kommt
vielen dank
jeweils zwei fragen stehen
als der deutschland ist auch der
russischen seite so bitte geht an
michael hübner von der drückenden
präsident putin sie haben gleichzeitig
signalisiert dass sie dem dialog sehen
und haben gleichzeitig kritik hat der
bundeskanzler nicht genug mitgebracht
besonders von präsident seelands die mit
diesem zusicherungen und die frage die
sich alle euro herstellen ist trotz
dieser enge beziehungen zu russland wird
es nochmal krieg geben in europa
schließen sie jetzt im augenblick krieg
aus new
york und herr bundeskanzler an sie die
frage wie schätzen sie denn jetzt die
lage nach diesem gespräch ein
gab es fortschritte so wie sie sich das
vorgestellt haben und was muss der
nächste schritt sein
was den krieg in europa anbelangt der
bundeskanzler hat eben gesagt
dass die menschen seiner generation und
ich zähle nicht dazu sich kaum
vorstellen können irgendeinen krieg in
europa vorstellen können
das ist natürlich im hinblick auf die
situation um der ukraine
gesprochen aber wir waren doch zeugen
des krieges
in europa und zwar von den von der nato
entfesselte krieg gegen jugoslawien es
war eine große militärische operation
mit raketen und bombenangriffen
gegenüber in einer der europäischen
hauptstädten belgrad das hatten wir doch
ohne samson de oder
sicherheitsrat
das ist ein sehr schlechtes beispiel
aber wir hatten so was das ist
das wollen oder nicht natürlich nicht
gerade deswegen
haben wir unsere vorschläge unterbreitet
den
verhandlungsprozess vom einzuleiten das
sind ergebnisse einer vereinbaren zur
gleichen
sicherheitsarchitektur inklusive unseres
landes voll zu machen leider das haben
wir auch erfolge haut und gab es keine
konkrete konstruktive antwort auf die
von unterbreitete vorschläge
nichtsdestotrotz gehen wir davon aus
dass selbst in den dokumenten die wir
erhalten haben von unseren partnern von
der nato und washington einige elemente
vorhanden sind die diskussions und
verhandlungsfähig sind wir sind aber
bereit diese zu verhandlungen erst
das gesamte grund rät grundsätzlichen
fragen wie für uns vorrangig sind und
ich habe heute ein bundeskanzler gesagt
wir gehen davon aus dass der dialog sich
gerade in der richtung
entwickeln wird und je nachdem wie sich
dieser druck entwickelt wird natürlich
auch sämtliche art alle anderen
richtungen entwickeln werden die sowohl
für sie als auch von uns große sorgen
hervorrufen glauben sie mir ich
glaube dass wir jetzt eine situation
haben es darauf ankommt alle
möglichkeiten zu nutzen keinen fanden
ungenutzt zu lassen und dafür zu sorgen
dass wir eine friedlich ein bisschen
möglich machen
das ist der grund warum mich gerichtet
habe das für den minister prozess jetzt
wichtige voraussetzungen auch
angekündigt sind mit den entsprechenden
gesetzesvorhaben aus meiner sicht muss
das auch dazu beitragen dass jetzt die
gespräche in den trilateralen
kontaktgruppe aufgenommen werden können
über diese vorschläge und dass das dann
auch ein ausgangspunkt ist für eine
friedliche lösung der situation in der
ukraine
zwischen dem mit dem don was und mit der
ukrainischen regierung
was für mich wichtig ist es dass die
gespräche dort stattfindenden dieser
trilateralen kontaktgruppe das ist das
was im menschen miteinander vereinbart
worden ist und darauf arbeiten wir hin
dass das möglich wird hier gerne noch
mal sagen dass ich glaube dass es in
jugoslawien eine etwas andere situation
gab es gab die gefahr eines
völkermordes und das musste verhindert
werden ich bin froh dass wir
mittlerweile eine friedliche entwicklung
haben und dass die länder des balkans
alle eine eigene perspektive jeweils in
richtung der europäischen union gefunden
haben aus sich heraus ich glaube das ist
ein gutes zeichen
ist das was heute in dallas stattfindet
ist unsere erste volker matt ist genozid
ria nowosti bitte ihre frage
ich habe eine große frage
zum umfangreichen im bereich ein
bundeskanzler sind gerade aus kiel
zurückgekehrt wo sie mit präsident
salems ging gesprochen haben was glauben
verwehrt und wird g und ist willig ist
sehr schwierig die vereinbarung liminski
vereinbarungen zu erfüllen umzusetzen
es heute nachrichten würden teilweise
für eine teilweisen rückzug der truppen
dann haben die
duma-abgeordneten als sie mit einem auf
mit einem bauantrag herangekommen
ich kann auch nicht umhin zu fragen
dort trieben zwei wie sieht das aus
welche drohungen und welche perspektiven
gestellte unter putin bitte
entschuldigen sie noch einmal sie tragen
ihr alter bekannter herr schröder
großen kritik ausgesetzt worden was
können sie in diesem zusammenhang sagen
dankeschön
die abstimmung in der domain
staatsduma ich habe gerade kurz vor der
konferenz das erfahren die mitarbeiter
meiner verwaltung haben das mitgeteilt
und teilweise rückzug der
trocken aus dem manöver gebiet was kann
ich dazu kommentieren was das
exekutivorgan unter anderem um
militärisch politischen führung das
daran dass er gibt es nichts zu
kommentieren es ist beschlossen
teilweise drohen zurück zum vierten die
abstimmung in der staatsduma wird der so
oder anders mit diesem thema auch
zusammenhängen denn der abgeordnete des
parlaments richten sich nach der
öffentlichen meinung
nach der meinung ihre wählerschaft zu
spüren spüren diese meinung das ist
offensichtlich lassen größter mehrzahl
der menschen in unserem lande mitgefühl
mit den worten von abbas haben
unterstützen sie und hoffen dass die
situation dort sich grundsätzlich
hoffentlich in die bessere für diese
einrichtung verbessern weil es gab zwei
projekte natürlich weiß die eine das
eigene russland hat ein projekt
vorgestellt und das andere ist ein
tapferes projekt das ist unmittelbarer
andere antrag an den präsidenten um
diese zwei republiken zu erkennen es war
eine offene abstimmung eine freie
abständen deswegen gab es keine partei
zwang und wurde als partei- plan wurde
ausgesetzt und die meisten abgeordneten
haben die resolution unterstützt
von der
oppositionspartei
unterbreitet wurde ich werde
alles mögliche tun sollen um dieses
problem zu lösen aber tun sollen wer es
wie herr bundeskanzler eben gesagt hat
vor allem
wenn wir davon ausgehen dass die nicht
voll ausgeschöpft möglichkeit
implementiert werden und wir müssen also
das
hoffen und rechnen damit dass unsere
partner im übersee aber auch in europa
vor allem bundesrepublik deutschland und
frankreich einen einfluss auf die ikea
war
darüber macht was was herr schröder und
streams zwei anbelangt ich hab schon
heute wo das ganze
also anfang von 2000 haben wir eine
absprache mit der ukraine
damals stand präsidenten der ukraine
unter schröder hat damals
von großer zahl und wir haben damals
eine vereinbarung über eine
internationales konsortium
aus
deutschland
und zwar fing eines konsortiums der in
dieser gastransportsystem
manager
und geld und sonstige ressourcen alle
unterstützung dieser des
gastransportsystems
die nächste regierung
mit herrschen gehabt diese
verweigerte hat
unterstützt 55 milliarden 55 prozent der
gaslieferung com über diese gasleitung
über nacht im 1 und geliefert wird ganz
nach den flüchtigen lieferkontrakte
oder sie einfach niedriger sind die
preise in diesem vertrag vorgesehen die
unter
anderem auch bei spot markt
die deutsche verbraucher sowohl
privatverbraucher als auch
das russische gas das fünf mal billiger
elster
vorbereitet 35 mal teurer
strom und wärme aus wenn nicht dann soll
er sich daheim scheurer bedanken denn
wir haben dem schröder des folter zu
bedanken dass es ist war es seine
präsenz in der verwaltungsorgane von
gazprom anbelangt
so sind sehr viele in europa heute
besorgt darum besorgt ob die
regel messe
nach russland fortgesetzt werden wenn
ein solcher beschluss gefasst wird der
herr schröder
aufsichtsratmitglied werden kann in der
karte für die kontrolle
der herr schröder ist der absoluten
anständige menschen ist den wir sehr
respektiert und der vor allem
der aufbau der aufgabe stellte die
interessen seines eigenen landes nämlich
der bundesrepublik deutschland
umzusetzen dann wird der bundesrepublik
deutschland und der europäer in diesem
gremium eine person haben die durch
mittels dessen
anschlüsse beeinflusst werden können und
von der kunde über den
ich glaube
man sollte sich eigentlich darauf freuen
ich glaube das wird erstmal im juni
aktuell sind aber das ist jetzt das
anlegen von gazprom und des unabhängigen
experten herrn schröder selbst was nur
streams 2 andre lang
übrigens dass das dasein von herrn
schröder im aufsichtsrat er ist absolut
natürlich denn er war unmittelbar mit
der gründung und mit dem aufbau von
astrium 1
beteiligt ich wiederhole bei der
finanzierung des projektes sind
55 gesellschaften beteiligt darunter
zwei deutsche
seit dezember letzten jahres bereits
industriell in betrieb zu gehen es geht
nur um den deutschen regulierer der ein
entsprechendes entsprechenden beschluss
zur lieferung gaslieferungen über diese
möglichkeit freizugeben zu treffen
zunächst war die frage nach den
vereinbarungen die müssen sich alle
halten das gilt für die regierung der
ukraine das gilt selbstverständlich
russland deutschland und frankreich die
beteiligt sind an den politischen
prozess der dazu gehört und deshalb ist
es so wichtig dass alle ihren beitrag
leisten einen beitrag ist das jetzt all
die gesetzentwürfe zur verfügung stehen
werden die notwendig sind um darüber zu
reden wie die drei großen aufgaben
gelöst werden die ich bereits in meinem
eingangsstatement erwähnt habe und eben
etwas zu tun haben mit dem speziellen
statut mit den wahlen mit der steinmeier
formel und selbstverständlich mit dem
verfassungsfragen alles das wird
vorliegen und dann wird in dem
trilateralen format zwischen der ukraine
russland und der oecd und den weiteren
beteiligten darüber zu sprechen sein das
ist das was vereinbart ist und dieser
prozess sollte von allen unterstützt
werden und von niemandem aufgehalten
werden jeder leicht natürlich dazu die
dinge zu seinen gunsten auszulegen aber
in wahrheit steht alles aufgeschrieben
und mein wunsch ist dass alle sich
eindruck geben und jetzt das schon
einmal vereinbarte in eine verständigung
übersetzen das noch viel zu diskutieren
gibt aber wo der nächste schritt jetzt
mal erfolgen sollen das ist jedenfalls
mein wunsch und die voraussetzungen sind
dafür da wenn alle sich einen ruck geben
kann es auch klappen aber nur dann
selbstverständlich würde
das bedeuten die meistens gar
vereinbarung zu missachten die
resolution die das parlament heute
getroffen hat realität würde ich glaube
das wissen auch alle beteiligten deshalb
geht es nicht um diese resolution die
würde dagegen sprechen dann wäre der
prozess abgebrochen und beendet das wäre
eine politische katastrophe sondern das
ginge nur wenn dann gewissermaßen alle
wieder zurückkehren zu dieser
vereinbarung hat der see eingangs
gefragt haben und er hat im klare
kriterien
was
nachdem zwei betrifft
hätte ich die privat wirtschaftlichen
aktivitäten eines früheren politikers
nicht weiter kommentieren er spricht
nicht für die bundesrepublik deutschland
sondern für sich
was die pipeline selber betrifft
wir sind alle was los ist
wir haben uns verpflichtet
sicherzustellen dass der gastransit in
europa funktioniert über die ukraine
belarus und polen mit dem streamen 1
insgesamt entsprechend der
vereinbarungen die wir haben und dafür
werden wir auch sorge tragen wir wollen
sicherstellen dass wir eine friedliche
entwicklung in europa zustande bekommen
dass es nicht zu einer militärischen
konfrontation in der ukraine kommt wenn
es doch so ist dann wird das
weitreichende konsequenzen haben darüber
sind sich auch alle klar hier jedenfalls
wissen was dann zu tun ist und mein
eindruck ist dass das auch alle anderen
ganz genau wissen die verstehen was los
ist und
verstehen auch die politischen
realitäten in dem wir uns dann bewegen
deshalb gibt es ja jetzt darum dass wir
alles dafür tun exakt diese situation zu
vermeiden indem wir auf eine friedliche
entwicklung setzen und als wahre
politische führer erweisen die den
beitrag dazu leisten dass nicht nur
jeder mit dem finger auf den anderen
zeigt sondern jeder sein weit und
leistet dazu dass der friede bewahrt
werden kann das ist die aufgabe die wir
haben
als nächstes michael fischer von dpa
vielen dank herr bundeskanzler zuerst an
sie eine frage sie haben eben schon
angesprochen dass sie
schwierige themen in den deutsch
russischen beziehungen in ihrem gespräch
mit präsident putin angesprochen haben
sie haben mit real genannt sie haben die
deutschen welle genannt es gibt ja noch
andere themen zum beispiel den fall
einer reihe nidda hat heute einen
prozess begonnen es gibt die
medizinischen zwangs tests für ausländer
es gibt die russischen cyberattacken auf
deutschland haben sie auch das
angesprochen auf welche resonanz sind
sie da gestoßen bei präsident putin und
wie würden sie den zustand der deutsch
russischen beziehungen insgesamt
beschreiben und dann sehr präsident
putin die nachfrage nochmals zudem zu
den ersten schritten des truppenabzugs
heute wie wird das in den nächsten tagen
und wochen weitergehen werden weitere
truppen abgezogen
können sie einen angriff auf die ukraine
heute ausschließen und eine frage zu
der zum nato-beitritt der ukraine
die nahe die bundeskanzler scholz und
auch andere staats und regierungschefs
der nato sind ja nicht bereit eine
garantie dafür abzugeben dass die
ukraine nicht in die nato aufgenommen
worden ist können sie sich aber
vielleicht ein moratorium vorstellen
denn es wird er jetzt gesagt von nato
seite dass ein solcher beitritt in den
nächsten jahren vielleicht sogar
jahrzehnten unrealistisch ist
wir haben viele themen angesprochen ich
habe über einige berichtet was dann
navalny betrifft es meine haltung sind
klar und rechtsstaatlichen grundsätzen
ist eine verurteilung nicht vereinbaren
und diese position habe ich schon vielen
gelegenheiten zum ausdruck gebracht
ich möchte
ist das der oberste boss ist mir ich
habe verstanden dass ich nun der frage
zu beantworten erst und
russland weiter agieren soll
planmäßig
woraus besteht dieser plan aus der
realen situation aus der vor ort
wer kann diese frage beantworten wie
diese lage tatsächlich entwickelt
niemand bis dato niemand es hängt nicht
nur von uns ab aber wir sind gewollt
gewillt
das
und mit unseren partnern vereinbarungen
zu treffen um diplomatische antworten
auf die gestellten fragen zu stellen
welcher sind es sind das bekannt was die
sicherheitsgarantie von russland das ist
nicht erweiterung von der radtour die
täglichen infrastruktur bis zum jahr 79
97 und nicht fraktionierung der angriff
komplexen in der nähe von unserer
grenzen das ist eines klar wir sind
bereit auch andere themen zu besprechen
die in der von uns erhalten antwort
erhalten sind aber eben zu haben mit dem
was wir uns primäre bedeutung und
bedeutung hat
die zweite können sie bitte den zweiten
teil wiederholen ich habe irgendetwas
gekritzelt aber
es ging es ging um den truppenabzug von
der ukrainischen grenze und um die
erweiterung
rückzug anbelangt habe ich das bereits
gesagt ich glaube diesen teil der frage
der frage habe ich beantragt die
nato-erweiterung sie haben wunderbar
übrigens eine wunderbar gesagt es wird
gemunkelt dass in den absehbaren zeit
russland kein mitglied der nato und
etwas heißt es wird gesprochen
was heißt es wird gemunkelt was heißt
dass er in den zwischenstaatlichen
beziehungen
30 jahren bereits hören wir das ist
kein zoll in richtung große grenzen
stattfinden soll und hier sehen wir die
infrastruktur der nato unmittelbar vor
unserem haus mehr als das
beitritt der ukraine in die nato es wird
gesprochen das wird nicht morgen aber
wann
was ändert das für uns in der
historischen perspektive
eigentlich gar nichts rein gar nichts
wir hören
dass der ukraine nicht
beizutreten diese these ist uns bekannt
und
gleichzeitig wird gesagt
dass morgen aktuell nicht aufgenommen
wird aber erst dann aufgenommen wenn sie
vorbereitet wird aber für uns könnte
auch das bereits zu spät sein deswegen
haben merken wir möchten wir diese frage
jetzt schon geklärt wissen direkt in den
absehbaren zeit im laufe der
verhandlungen
und zwar mit friedlichen mitteln davon
gehen wir aus und wir hoffen sehr dass
unsere
dass unsere dass unsere sorgen von ihren
partnern gehört und akzeptiert würden
guten tag ich möchte meine erste frage
schon gestern bei würden das treffen
entfernt also drauf haben sie
garantien für russland gesprochen und
waren eigentlich das ist perspektiven
führt der fluss das mit der
verhandlungen möglich sind heißt es doch
schon langjährige anhand anhaltenden
verhandlungen bevor stellt der
hauptsache die aber die drei punkten die
sie von washington abgelehnt werden auch
beim auch
berücksichtigt bin erste erfragen ich
muss an herrn der chance und herrn boot
in frage
in deutschland
gibt es möglichkeit ein dass eine
vernünftige perspektivische lösung
dieses problems geben dann wird wir als
russia today in russland weiter
erstrahlt und die deutsche welle in
die deutsche welle die frage also
deutsche war bereits bei herrn kannst du
auch wir haben heute mit bundeskanzler
gebrochen der arbeit von der deutschen
welle in russland sowie der arbeit von
der bundesrepublik deutschland
ich möchte jetzt wirklich nicht
die situation unnötig nicht unnötig zu
erschweren
wir werden aber uns überlegen wie wir
diese probleme lösen können
langanhaltende verhandlungsprozess ja
gerade deswegen haben wir mit dem wind
außenminister gästen auch mit anderen
kollegen aus dem
ministerium besprochen natürlich gibt
diese besorgnis bei uns auch und die
besteht darin dass wir
also wir haben befürchtungen
dass verhandlungsprozess zu den von uns
unterbreiteten
wesentlichen fragen in
sicherheitsrelevanten fragen
von unseren partner währungspartner
unbegründet in die länge geschoben
werden konnte und so oder anders
beschlüsse oder
beschlüsse getroffen werden die unsere
lage
erschweren uns schlechter machen werden
und zwar so wie es bis jetzt im laufe
von im laufe von vielen jahren der fall
war das ist eigentlich im mittelpunkt
unserer aufmerksamkeit ist wir verstehen
das und das ist das was wir zweifelsohne
zu besprechen haben mit unseren partnern
und das ist es das was wir auf keinen
fall zulassen werden
zunächst mal die frage hat die sie
gestellt haben das ist ein
rechtsstaatliches verfahren indem können
anträge gestellt werden auch solche die
bisher nicht gestellt wurden und die
werden dann ordnungsgemäß von den
zuständigen behörden bearbeitet
das geschieht nach gesetzen die bereits
existieren und auf die sich jeder
gleichmäßig berufen kann darauf können
sich alle verlassen aber es gibt ein
rechtsstaatliches verfahren da müssen
die voraussetzungen stimmen
ich will noch etwas sagen zu der
situation der gespräche
die positionen sind unterschiedlich dass
es klar geworden darum haben wir uns
lange unterhalten das ist auch richtig
aber es ist immerhin so dass
mittlerweile gesprochen wird und ich
finde richtig dass die nato die
europäische union auf die briefe
russlands geantwortet haben und das ist
ein gutes zeichen dass russland zwar
nicht einverstanden ist mit der antwort
aber sagt da sind ein paar gute dinge
drin und umgekehrt ist es so dass mit
den vorstellungen die russland
formulierte die nato die eu auch wir
nicht einverstanden sind aber da sind
ein paar punkte drin über die es nun
miteinander zu reden und das was jetzt
notwendig ist damit es nicht zu einer
gefährlichen situation in europa chance
die wir alle vermeiden müssen ist dass
jeder weiß das ist schon ganz viel
kleine ansätze für gespräche und dass
man sie dann auch real führen muss um
all die fragen die wichtig sind das
fängt an bei der frage der lösung dieser
problematik der ukraine mit dem minsker
vereinbarung und den prozess der dazu
vereinbart ist an dem sich alle präzise
halten müssen und mit innerem willen auf
einen erfolg miteinander sprechen müssen
das gilt auch für die unterschiedlichen
positionen zur frage der
nato-osterweiterung
da es ja die etwas eigenwillige
situation dass die gar nicht ansteht
besteht nicht auf der tagesordnung jeder
weiß das ganz genau
das ist kein thema das uns
wahrscheinlich in unseren ämtern
begegnen wird wieder
solange wir sie ausüben ich weiß nicht
wie lange der präsident vor hat das amt
zu sein aber ich jedenfalls habe das
gefühl das könnte länger dauern aber
nicht ewig und insofern werden wir
deshalb doch die aufgabe haben jetzt aus
dieser diesem punkt etwas zu machen dass
man miteinander zu einer politischen
verständigung führen kann ohne dass
irgendjemand seine grundsätze seine
prinzipien habe aufgeben muss das ist
politische führung und das ist
verantwortung die wir gegenüber unseren
ländern die wir regieren und dem
internationalen frieden und der
zusammenarbeit in europa haben und darum
geht es dann auch wenn wir insgesamt
über die spreche fragen sprechen die
wichtig sind für sicherheit und
zusammenarbeit in europa über fragen von
transparenz und über fragen von
rüstungskontrolle der wunsch ist von
allen formuliert die nato hat das
positiv beantwortet dann auch anders als
gewünscht aber immerhin da ist ein
ausgangspunkt und wir sollten die
ausgangspunkte nutzen um unsere
verantwortung gerecht zu werden
was die mobile gibt das gefühl dass er
vielen dank der vielen vielen dank den
kollegen die konferenz soll mit hiermit
beendet
eine verdammte pflicht und aufgabe von
start von staatsmännern und frauen von
staatsoberhäuptern hatte scholz das
genannt die verdammte pflicht und
aufgabe kriegerische eskalation zu
verhindern so da war viel drin in dieser
pressekonferenz und wir sind auch so
reingestolpert weil sie früher losgehen
als das eigentlich angekündigt war
deswegen jetzt ganz in ruhe wollen wir
mit euch das ganze aufarbeiten einordnen
das was wir gerade gehört haben aber
auch was bislang heute schon passiert
ist denn seit wochen war eigentlich die
situation bislang wie folgt russland
hatte zehntausende soldaten an der
grenze zur ukraine stationiert und heute
dann plötzlich die meldung dass also
einige ein teil dieser truppen nun
abziehen soll das war heute auch noch
eine meldung über die wir noch sprechen
wollen und die große frage natürlich was
hat das zu bedeuten wie geht es weiter
was haben wir da also auch gerade auf
der pressekonferenz von beiden seiten
deutschland und russland gehört wir
haben uns gäste dazu eingeladen mit
denen wir sprechen können aber zunächst
mal auch live aus moskau die
einschätzung von meinem kollegen von
christian selben unserem korrespondent
vor ort christian ich hoffe du kannst
mich jetzt hören und sehen wunderbar ich
sehe und höre dich wir haben beide die
pressekonferenz verfolgt was würde sony
soll halo schönen guten abend christian
was hast du am meisten für den botschaft
vernommen vielleicht sowohl von der
russischen seite als auch von der
deutschen seite was stand da für dich
heute als überschrift über diesem
gespräch
also die botschaft die ich jetzt am
meisten mitgenommen habe von diesem
treffen ist dass es eine
dialogbereitschaft gibt und die haben
beide seiten betont ich habe gestern
diese situation als als das bild gab als
wladimir putin gemeinsam mit sergej
lawrow an diesem riesigen langen tisch
saß und sie über die antwort geredet
haben die sie bekommen haben auf die
vorschläge der russischen
sicherheitsgarantien und da wurde auch
schon verlautbart dass es raum für
dialog gibt und das haben jetzt beide
seiten noch mal betonen sowohl olaf
scholz als auch wladimir putin dass in
diesem antwortschreiben ist natürlich
nicht alles drin was russland zufrieden
gestellt aber es gibt punkte über die
man reden kann und andererseits sind in
den forderungen die von russland aus
gehen wir werden natürlich auch nicht
alle erfüllt sagt olaf scholz aber auch
da gibt es punkte über die man
diskutieren kann also finde ich haben
beide heute schon die perspektive
eröffnet dass es raum gibt für weitere
gespräche verhandlungen und dialog ein
punkt der ja da auch immer wieder
genannt wird er immer wieder kommt
natürlich von russischer seite in die
forderung auch jetzt zum ende der
pressekonferenz war das also noch mal
thema die forderung dass ukraine kein
nato-mitglied wird auch dazu hat sich
bundeskanzler scholz jetzt am ende noch
mal geäußert dieses thema was da immer
im raum steht also die nato
osterweiterung was ist da quasi heute
nicht beschlossen wurden aber was es da
heute besprochen worden so
ich fand es erstaunlich gestern war olaf
scholz ja schon in kiel von 1 gab es die
pressekonferenz nach dem treffen mit dem
ukrainischen präsidenten selent ski und
da hat sich olaf scholz schon ähnlich
geäußert und hat gesagt naja diese
diskussion über die jemand nato
mitgliedschaft der ukraine das stünde ja
gar nicht an das hat präsident selensky
naturgemäß anders gesehen und das wurde
im prinzip schon vorausgeschickt nach
moskau vor diesem treffen und jetzt
heute hat er das eben auch noch mal
betont dass er das nicht sieht solange
er sozusagen im amt ist nun hat in
seiner amtszeit gerade erst begonnen hat
das dann ein bisschen schmunzelt
vielleicht eine richtung wladimir putin
gesagt er wisse ja nie wissen ja nicht
wie lange putin noch im amt bleiben
würde aber das sieht er in der namens
hatten nahmen zeiten nicht kommen
insofern
sieht da glaube ich auch nicht wirklich
dieses diskussionsgrundlage obwohl das
thema immer wieder so hoch gehängt wird
in den letzten tagen gab es eine große
sorge wie hebt diese situation da an der
grenze zur ukraine was da jetzt passiert
ob das womöglich bald eskaliert weil
einfach so viele russische truppen dort
stationiert waren dann wir haben schon
kurz angesprochen also die plötzliche
meldung heute ein teil dieser truppen
soll quasi abziehen russland bleibt ja
auch dabei das sei alles eine übung eine
militärübung für die menschen in der
ukraine die die truppen vor der haustür
haben ist das natürlich alles keine
übung aber was hat das heute zu bedeuten
heute an diesem tag den die amerikaner
zuvor ja auch als einen tag gesehen
haben an dem vielleicht alles eskalieren
könnte das stand so im raum und jetzt
heute also die eher die ansage von
russland neder passiert heute gar nichts
im gegenteil gruppen werden teilweise
abgezogen wie ist das einzuschätzen
ich glaube man kann das schon als
deeskalation angebot sehen und so hat es
auch der deutsche bundeskanzler
aufgefasst hat sich dazu eben auch
geäußert bei der pressekonferenz aus
russischer sicht kann man aber sagen
dass das jetzt heute nicht überraschend
auf gefloppt ist sondern dass das vor
zwei tagen auch schon angekündigt wurde
und auch schon in gesprächen immer
vorher also vor längerer zeit schon hat
zum beispiel auch der russische
außenminister immer wieder gesagt und
betont wir machen übungen auf unserem
territorium das da können wir sozusagen
machen was wir wollen wenn diese übungen
abgeschlossen sind dann werden sich die
soldaten auch wieder zurückziehen
insofern ist das jetzt aus russischer
sicht glaube ich nie keinen
kommunizierte
zugeständnis für eine deeskalation
sollen einfach ein selbstverständnis
dass man auf dem eigenen territorium
machen kann was man will und dann weiß
man natürlich auch noch nicht wie viele
truppen werden da wirklich abgezogen ist
ja wirklich ein massiver aufmarsch
gewesen auch wieviel gerät wird
vielleicht zurückgelassen und man kann
sich das natürlich auch so vorstellen es
gab ja schon mal im letzten jahr ein
truppenaufmarsch dann wurden die truppen
wieder zurückgezogen jetzt in diesem
jahr war es eben sehr massiv und putin
wenn man das als spielball bezeichnen
will hat diesen joker natürlich immer
wieder in der hand und wenn er das
gefühl hat dass die gespräche oder
dieser dialog der jetzt vielleicht noch
mehr ins rollen kommt wenn der ins
stocken gerät kann er natürlich die
truppen auch immer wieder an die grenze
bringen und das szenario wieder neu
aufrollen der russische außenminister
nach drauf hat sich auch heute zu diesem
teil teilweise truppenabzug geäußert da
hören wir mal kurz rein
die signale die aus moskau kommende mann
weiterhin offen gegenüber diplomatischer
bemühungen ist das stimmt uns vorsichtig
optimistisch
aber natürlich werden wir sehr genau
verfolgen was auf dem boden passiert und
ob sich das in echter deeskalation in
form von truppenabzug rund um die
ukraine äußert
die militärübungen die jetzt ablaufen
und ablaufen werden sie laufen ganz nach
unserem vorher angekündigten zeitplan ab
das haben wir schon mehrfach gesagt und
was die übungen im äussersten und osten
des landes sowie die gemeinsamen übungen
mit belarus angeht alles läuft genau wie
geplant es hat nichts damit zu tun wer
was denkt oder wer hysterie in form von
informations terrorismus verbreitet wenn
ich das mal so sagen darf
etwas vorschnell haben wir euch auch
schon die reaktionen von
nato-generalsekretär stoltenberg im
vorfeld mit gegeben also jetzt habt ihr
beides gehört auf der einen seite
reaktion vom nato general sekretär und
aber eben auch heute die äußerung von
russischen außenminister wir haben auch
eine frage aus dem stream direkt jetzt
mal zu der situation zu der lage in
russland und zwar möchte axel baruschke
bei facebook wissen wie steht denn die
bevölkerung bevölkerung in russland zu
diesem thema aktuell
geht die frage an mich ja wir wissen im
moment noch mein einziger
gesprächspartner
okay ja wir haben natürlich in den
letzten tagen auch immer wieder mit den
russinnen und russen gesprochen und mein
eindruck ist ähnlich wie das auch in der
ukraine ist die meisten können sich hier
keinen krieg vorstellen und es fehlt
schlichtweg auch die fantasie dafür und
es gibt natürlich auch hier in russland
viele familien die auch familiäre
bindungen eben noch in die ukraine haben
und da können sich die menschen hier
nicht vorstellen dass es wirklich einen
krieg geben wenn es dazu käme dann ist
vielen auch klar dass er sehr blutig
enden würde und ich habe nicht das
gefühl dass hier in der russischen
bevölkerung
eine stimmung herrscht in der man
wirklich an krieg
über die ukrainische seite werden wir in
dieser sendung auch noch sprechen das
sei gesagt natürlich du bist für uns in
moskau hast für uns die sicht auf all
das was in russland passiert jetzt ist
da natürlich auch heute das war eine
verhandlung von vielen das ist nicht so
dass da jetzt zum ersten mal verhandelt
wurde es war ja gleichzeitig auch der
antrittsbesuch von scholz er war nun
also zu gast zuvor war auch schon der
französische präsident beispielsweise zu
gast aber das ganze geht ja jetzt schon
seit wochen hin und her gab es da heute
die aussicht dass sich das vielleicht
jetzt auch ein bisschen kürzer fassen
könnte weil wie lange soll sich das
ganze noch ziehen haben die beiden uns
da irgendeine aussicht gegeben
das ist eine gute frage du hast das ja
schon angesprochen ist so viele
hochrangige gespräche wie in den letzten
wochen gab es hier ganz lange nicht mehr
in moskau und ich denke es wurde auch
immer wieder spekuliert was will putin
was für putin wirklich im schilde will
er wirklich an krieg oder was ist eine
intention und ich habe den eindruck dass
er da schon ganz viel erreicht hat denn
so viele hochrangige gespräche auf
diesem niveau und alle in moskau er muss
ja noch nicht mal irgendwohin fahren
sondern sie kommen alle zu ihm und es
wird natürlich über den konflikt in der
ukraine gesprochen aber auch immer ganz
viele andere themen
bilaterale themen namens in der
pressekonferenz auch gehört die
themenpalette zwischen deutschland und
russland ist sehr groß und so hat er es
geschafft diese hochrangigen gespräche
zu kriegen und ich denke damit kann er
erst mal zufrieden sein und wenn es
weiter in diesen dialog können wir
sicherlich davon ausgehen dass es auch
weitere hochrangige gespräche geben wird
und dass putin sich diese möglichkeit
natürlich auch nicht nehmen lässt
vielen dank christian sam für die
einschätzung für den moment und
jetzt wollen wir natürlich auch über die
ukrainische seite sprechen und das haben
wir uns einen neuen gesprächsgast
eingeladen und zwar kann ich jetzt mit
predator triebe sprechen von der
konrad-adenauer-stiftung während
christian genau uns jetzt verletzt sehen
wir jetzt schon predator triebe schönen
guten abend herzlich willkommen sie
leiteten oder leiten immer noch das
auslandsbüro in der ukraine in kharkiv
40 kilometer nur von der russischen
grenze entfernt
warum ich das aber eben kurz und mich so
versprochen habe ist der grund sie sind
jetzt gerade nicht mehr in der ukraine
sie gehören zu den menschen die also
jetzt vor ein paar tagen ausgeflogen
sind aus der ukraine und wir erreichen
sie nun also auch in deutschland schon
guten abend
gute nano sie haben natürlich jeden tag
täglich kontakt mit den menschen in
relativ in der ukraine und was hören sie
von dort wie geht es also denen die da
eben jetzt nicht das land verlassen
konnten in den letzten tagen und wir
schätzen die auf die bedrohung im land
selbst ein
ja natürlich sind diese entwicklung in
den letzten wochen das thema nummer eins
gerade in hartz iv gelesen und in der
ostukraine der insgesamt weil die
menschen muslija tagtäglich hören dass
ihre heimat schauplatz eines
potenziellen großen krieges werden
könnte
dennoch muss ich sagen auch die letzten
wochen ich war bis letzte woche bis in
der letzten woche in hagnau war die
stimmung dort vor ort doch noch sehr
ruhig ich würde es als angespannte ruhe
bezeichnen denn viele menschen haben mir
gesagt wir kennen diese situation ja wir
sind ja seit acht jahren in einem
kriegerischen konflikt mit russland
deswegen würde ich wenn ich mir das
erlauben darf ihren korrespondenten
etwas korrigieren die ukrainische
bevölkerung kann sich sehr gut einen
kriegerischen konflikt mit russland
vorstellen dass konnten sie 2014 nichts
aber diesen schock mussten sich schon
einmal erleben und deswegen haben wir
viele personen gesagt wir sind
vorbereitet auf den ernstfall glauben
nicht an eine umfassende invasion der
russischen seite aber wenn es passiert
sind wir wie gesagt
vorbereitet in der ukraine hat man eher
damit gerechnet oder bis heute rechnet
man damit dass russland
weiter versuchen wird die ukraine zu
destabilisieren also das heißt dass die
lage im don was sicherlich sich in
nächster zeit nicht entspannen wird aber
es vielleicht auch entwicklung im süden
der ukraine geben kann wenn es um den
wasserzugang zog canori
genau da gibt es absolut zwei seiten
christiansen bezog sich also auf die
russische perspektive jetzt natürlich
sehr spannend ihre seite mit der
ukrainischen perspektive das sind ja
nämlich wirklich zwei seiten und sie
haben es außerdem auch angesprochen dass
der krieg und flucht in der ukraine für
die ukraine nicht neu ist dass da eben
also seid 2014 kriegerische
auseinandersetzungen gibt und ich meine
wir haben dazu auch ein stück
vorbereitet was den hintergrund noch mal
gut erklärt von christian ruff aus wenn
es das würde ich gerne mal reinschauen
wunderbar der konflikt zwischen russland
und dem westen wurzelt in den jahren
nach der wiedervereinigung
die nato habe damals versprochen sich
nicht weiter nach osten an die grenzen
russlands auszudehnen behauptet russland
heute dennoch schließen sich polen
ungarn tschechien rumänien bulgarien und
auch die baltischen staaten sukzessive
der nato an russland bezeichnet das
heute als verrat aber das war nicht
immer so im gegenteil in mehreren
verträgen hat moskau den osteuropäern
zugesagt ihr bündnis frei wählen zu
dürfen
1990 etwa in der charta von paris oder
später noch einmal in der nato russland
grundakten
dann 2008 billig die nato georgien eine
langfristige beitrittsperspektive zu
aber die haltung russlands hat sich
geändert im august sollen russische
panzer über die grenze nach georgien
nach einem blitzkrieg erkennt moskau die
unabhängigkeit der gebiete südossetien
und abchasien an georgien verliert 20
prozent seines staatsgebietes
ende 2013 beginnt der konflikt mit der
ukraine nach der pro europäischen
revolution und den gewaltsamen
auseinandersetzungen auf dem majdan
annektiert russland die krim angeblich
um die russischsprachige bevölkerung vor
mord und gewalt zu schützen
der konflikt verlagert sich in den osten
der ukraine in die gebiete nur ans und
donetsk dort erobern separatisten die
macht unterstützt von russland der
westen beschließt wirtschaftssanktionen
sie werden nach dem abschuss von flug lh
17 über der ost ukraine verschärft
seit 2005 zehn versuchen deutschland und
frankreich zwischen der ukraine und
russland zu vermitteln die gespräche so
genannten normandie format sind aber
festgefahren bis heute hat der konflikt
mehr als 13.000 tote gefordert
haben es gehört 13.000 tote was macht
dieser konflikt dieser jahrelange jetzt
schon andauernde konflikt mit der
ukraine und den menschen dort
das war eine entschuldigung für sie sind
wieder bei mir und ich habe sie gefragt
was dieser dauerzustand dieses konflikts
was macht das mit der ukraine und den
menschen dort ja er hat massive folgen
die wir uns teilweise in deutschland gar
nicht vorstellen können weil wir haben
den konflikt in den letzten acht jahren
doch etwas vergessen also die ost
ukraine ist mit diesem konflikt eine
dauerhaft instabile region geworden das
hat
wirtschaftliche folgen es gibt kaum
perspektiven für die entwicklung die
menschen versuchen diese region zu
verlassen in dieser region aber auch in
der gesamten ukraine leben mehr als eine
million flüchtlinge die
teilweise unter sehr schwierigen
bedingungen versucht haben an sich ein
neues zuhause aufzubauen und ist hat
natürlich auch die ukraine grundsätzlich
verändert denn dieses land und viele
menschen in diesem land haben ja eher
positive dinge mit russland bis 2014
verboten gerade die ost ukraine die
wirtschaftlich historisch aber auch
privat
familie ist sehr sehr viele verbindungen
gab und das hat sich alles sei 2014
grundsätzlich geändert und das interesse
beispielsweise an einen nato-beitritt
der ukraine ist ja erst seit
2014 so angestiegen so dass es eben auch
jetzt von jeder ukrainischen regierung
immens
gefordert wird weil man eben dieses
russische vorgehen 2014 2015 auf der
krim und in dornbach als aggression
verstanden hat gegen die man sich
verteidigen muss jetzt gab es heute hier
die bestätigte meldung von einem
teilabzug vielleicht kann man das so
sagen also der truppen die an der grenze
zur ukraine statt entstanden ist das für
die menschen dort jetzt ein zeichen von
deeskalation oder glauben die menschen
in der ukraine da nicht dran
es ist definitiv schon mal eine bessere
nachricht als die nachrichten aus den
letzten tagen also gerade der abzug des
diplomatischen personals aber auch der
der staatsbürger viele starter auf der
ukraine hat doch noch einmal zu unruhe
und zu großer sorge gefühl aber in der
ukraine ist man sehr skeptisch bei
solchen meldungen
erst einmal ist nicht klar wie viele
truppen dort abgezogen worden sind
und man erhofft sich dann schon mehr
zeichen also es müssten mehr truppen
abgezogen werden die übung in belarus
gehen beispielsweise weiter und wir
dürfen auch nicht vergessen diese
auseinandersetzung wird jetzt sehr
intensiv mit informationen geführt und
mit mitteln der frieden kriegsführung
deswegen wird in der ukraine immer
wieder dran gezweifelt ob das dann
wirklich schon das zeichen der
deeskalation ist oder nicht doch
irgendeine russische taktik die dann
doch ein anderes ziel verfolgt vielen
dank für den moment für die einschätzung
ein privater triebe leiterin des
auslandsbüros der
konrad-adenauer-stiftung in haiti aktiv
in der ukraine vielen dank
danke
und jetzt gibt es natürlich auch noch
andere wichtige die da eine rolle
spielen anderen ländern zum beispiel die
usa denn dort oder mit den usa gab es in
den letzten tagen natürlich auch da gab
es meldungen aus den usa beispielsweise
gab es dort die meldung dass sie also
heute einen tag gesehen hatten so war es
eigentlich benannt an dem vielleicht
jetzt dieser diese situation an der
grenze zur ukraine auch eskalieren
könnte das stand im raum und deswegen
wollen wir jetzt dazu sprechen mit
unserem korrespondenten in washington
mit elmar theveßen
schönen guten abend
gute nacht lied hallo jetzt hatten die
usa die us geheimdienste da eine
situation vorher gesagt die er nach
eskalation als nach deeskalation klang
in den letzten tagen hatten also auch
ihre staatsbürger zur ausreise
aufgefordert und teilweise macht sich
russland darüber jetzt auch ein bisschen
lustig also die sprecherin des
russischen außenministeriums die soll
bei telegramm geschrieben haben der
fünfzehnte februar also heute wird als
tag des scheiterns der westlichen
kriegspropaganda in die geschichte
eingehen zitat hatten die usa das ganz
falsch eingeschätzt oder ist das alles
ein taktisches spiel
also die usa hatten tatsächlich den
sechzehnter februar benannt und zwar
basierend auf offenbar kommunikation die
man abgefangen hat mit aufklärungs
methoden der amerikanischen
geheimdienste dass zu diesem tag
kommandeure im feld in den verschiedenen
übungsgebiet
einsatzbereitschaft herstellen sollten
also es geht um den morgigen tag und
ehrlicherweise glaube ich dass die
amerikanischen nachrichtendienste auch
das weiße haus immer noch nicht von
entwarnung ausgehen und das hat auch mit
dem zu tun was man jetzt gerade in der
pressekonferenz gehört hat ich würde mal
sagen es werden drei punkte ganz
besonders aufgemerkt werden der erste
ist dialogbereitschaft das ist genau
dasselbe dass man in den letzten wochen
immer und immer wieder von der
russischen seite gehört hat auch bei den
treffen mit magna unter anderem aber
gleichzeitig sagt wladimir putin ja am
ende der pressekonferenz dass man von
grundsätzlichen punkten zb die frage ob
irgendwann ein beitritt zur nato für die
ukraine möglich ist nicht abrücken wird
also da ist man hier eher sachlich und
nüchtern was so eine ankündigung die
dialogbereitschaft angeht der zweite
punkt ist abzug von truppen teil abzug
von truppen da will man natürlich genau
verifizieren am boden und vielleicht
auch mit aufklärung ob das wirklich
stattfindet denn es gibt gemischte
signale gestern hieß es hier aus der
beobachtung der amerikaner das ganz
offenbar zusätzliche hubschrauber 60 auf
der krim gelandet sind auch das wäre
eine wichtige voraussetzung für einen
weiteren einmarsch gestern hieß es auch
dass die truppen in belarus die
russischen truppen dort
gefechtsbereitschaft gefechts positionen
eingenommen haben auch das ein hinweis
darauf dass es noch keine dsl
deeskalation gibt und deswegen ist man
hier sehr sehr skeptisch was das angeht
und der dritte punkt ist wladimir putin
sagt an einer stelle das was im don was
passiert ist völkermord da wird er hier
in den usa unverständnis mit herrschen
ernten weil man tatsächlich er der
meinung ist das ist eine art von
wahrnehmung die einen befürchten lassen
muss dass es in den nächsten tagen und
wochen vielleicht eher zu einer
deeskalation kommt als zu einer
wirklichen entschuldigung eskalation
kommt als zu einer wirklichen
deeskalation ja beide seiten werfen sich
da also immer wieder kriegspropaganda
vor und jetzt gehen die gespräche ja
auch schon eine weile also auch der
amerikanische außenminister war ja schon
auf osteuropa tour und war in russland
und das geht ja jetzt schon wirklich
eine ganze weile was ist die
einschätzung jetzt war also
bundeskanzler scholz dort folgt jetzt
als nächstes wieder ein besuch der
amerikaner oder wie ist das jetzt
einzuschätzen geht das ganze jetzt
schneller voran
ja die amerikaner nach wie vor nicht den
eindruck dass irgendwelche von den
angeboten die die nato ja gemacht hat
zum beispiel rüstungs begrenzung in
osteuropa zum beispiel begrenzung bei
der stationierung von raketen zum
beispiel auch mehr transparenz und
absprachen was manöver an den jeweiligen
grenzgebieten angeht dass russland in
irgendeiner weise auf diese ansätze
eingegangen wäre insofern hat sich die
position eigentlich seit januar aus
amerikanischer sicht nicht verändert
russland ist nicht offen bisher auf
diese angebote eingegangen man ist
deshalb skeptisch man schließt nicht aus
dass es noch eine deeskalation geben
kann aber momentan mit etwa 130000
truppen in grenznähe zur ukraine deutet
alles mehr in die andere richtung und
die amerikaner haben so eine art
leitfaden entwickelt sie nennen das
playbook sie haben in den vergangenen
monaten in einem kleinen team einmal
alle möglichen szenarien durchgespielt
was könnte russland tun wie sind die
reaktionen des westens der europäer und
der usa darauf alle möglichkeiten wurden
durchgespielt und basierend darauf wird
man jäh der einzelne bewegung zum
beispiel jetzt auch diesen angekündigten
teilabzug der truppen genau betrachten
und auch überlegen oder versuchen zu
prüfen ob es sich dabei um
desinformation und täuschung handelt und
in wahrheit der truppenaufmarsch an
anderen stellen weiter geht vielen dank
kiefers in washington für die
einschätzung
und jetzt können wir das ganze auch noch
ein bisschen mit hintergrund und
einschätzung auch noch mal von der
russischen perspektive beziehungsweise
also von der russischen seite was ist da
eigentlich genau los und wie geht es
weiter das können wir jetzt einordnen
und auch noch gerne mehr von euren
fragen wenn ihr sie den hauptstellen und
einbringen und zwar können wir diese
fragen stellen an sarah packung sie
forscht für die deutsche gesellschaft
für auswärtige politik und ist expertin
eben für russische außen und
sicherheitspolitik und deshalb heute bei
uns zu gast schönen guten abend
jetzt sind er heute ja im prinzip zwei
sachen passiert es gab also wieder
erneut gespräche zum einen zwischen
bundeskanzler scholz und dem russischen
präsidenten putin aber eben auch die
meldung über diesen plötzlichen
zumindest von außen betrachtet
plötzlichen teilabzug hat sie das denn
überrascht die dateien abzug der truppen
ja das kann auch für mich heute morgen
ist es durch die meldungen gegen
überraschend ich würde aber sagen jetzt
nach der pressekonferenz zwischen putin
und schaue jetzt wissen wir dass mehr es
gibt offensichtlich
noch mal erneut gespräche im minister
format um eine lösung für den don preis
der wahl zur führung ganz offensichtlich
hat scholz hat deutsches geschäft noch
mal druck auf die ukraine aufzulösen um
den ukrainischen teil der vereinbarung
möglicherweise zu erfüllen oder
zumindest näher heranzurücken und es
könnte sein dass das eben auch ein
schlüssel ist um oder anschlüsse war um
diesen zumindest
geringfügigen abzug in einigen bereichen
also wissen das ist jetzt wirklich etwas
beobachten können sehr eingespielt
herbeizuführen hier können allerdings
auch ich aus diesen das wissen bleibt
ist das heißt aus moskau ich auch immer
wieder also die truppen sind auf eigenem
gebiet also unterwegs und die würden
quasi nur ausgebildet das sei alles eine
eine übung wofür wird geübt also haben
sie da ein bisschen mehr quasi noch
insights für uns weil wenn das alles
eine übung ist dann gibt es ja
vielleicht auch ein grund wofür geübt
wird
grundsätzlich in militärischen übung
natürlich auch größte für das russische
militär wie auf jedes andere geht er
ganz normale ob sie sehen das ja bei der
nachwuchs dann unterschiedliche
szenarien beispielsweise die
landesregierung aber teilweise auch
angriffsszenario wir müssten jetzt aber
der fall weil die über die letzten ja
eigentlich vier monate in russland sehen
ganz klar sagen dass das überhaupt nicht
die eine übung aussieht nicht von der
struktur also die von qualität nicht von
quantität und wir einfach davon ausgehen
müssen dass das eine reine ablenkung
behauptung von russischer seite ist um
zu ihrem abzudecken dass die wirklich
wie möglich invasions bereitet dort
der empfang zu ihnen ist ein bisschen
ruckelig vielleicht können wir das sogar
auch noch im laufe des gesprächs
vielleicht wenn wir gleich noch einen
beitrag zusammen reinschauen vielleicht
noch mal ja wir heben ich wollte aber
kurz noch eine frage zu den weil wir da
gerade beim thema sind also zu den
soldaten abgezogen worden sind stellen
und zwar wohin werden die abgezogen was
weiß man da genau also wie geht es mit
den weiter die gehen jetzt also weg von
der grenze wohin
erstmal nur eben eine garnison sie nach
wie vor noch in der nähe der ukraine
sind also wir müssen auch ganz klar
sagen das geht noch nichts verraten
können von einem truppenabzug im
nördlichen bereich der kleinste auch in
belarus sondern wirklich nur die
westlichen bereich und dort eher ein
zurückziehen da truppen also ich glaube
wir müssen jetzt wir müssen noch sehr
vorsichtig sein und von einem
truppenabzug zu sprechen denn das was er
sich zurückgelegt wird an strecke das
ist bis jetzt noch nicht sehr viele noch
nicht sehr groß das ist etwas was man
sehr schnell wieder rückgängig machen
kann jetzt ging es heute in dem gespräch
zwischen bundeskanzler scholz und dem
russischen präsidenten schon auch
darüber natürlich wie kann man aber
miteinander im gespräch bleiben wie kann
es also zu einer friedlichen lösung
kommen und es gab ja bereits also auch
schon mal einen plan der frieden
herstellen sollte zwischen russland und
der ukraine das minsker abkommen und
auch darüber wollen wir gleich mal
sprechen und schauen uns vorher ein bei
von heiko kunzmann an
das minsker abkommen es soll
ursprünglich dem osten der ukraine
wieder frieden bringen im april 2014
hatten hier pro-russische separatisten
verwaltungen unter ihre kontrolle
gebracht in den jetzt und lugansk rufen
sie sogenannte unabhängige volksrepublik
'nen aus in minsk im benachbarten bilder
russ beginnen kurz darauf verhandlungen
eine waffenruhe wird vereinbart anfang
2015 musste der friedensplan
überarbeitet werden 2009 10 noch einmal
der plan sieht folgendes vor beide
seiten die ukraine und die separatisten
sollen gefangene austauschen und aus
einer pufferzone schwere artillerie
zurückziehen die regionen der
separatisten erhalten einen sonderstatus
regionale wahlen sind vorgesehen
außerdem verpflichtet sich die ukraine
die separatisten gebiete nicht länger
wirtschaftlich zu blockieren im gegenzug
sichern die separatisten zu der ukraine
wieder die kontrolle über die gesamte
russische ukrainische grenze
zurückzugeben das abkommen ist aber über
weite strecken bisher nicht umgesetzt
worden weil beide seiten die verträge
anders auslegen
beide werfen sich immer wieder
gegenseitig vor gegen das abkommen zu
verstoßen was ist da dran
also da ist schon was dran als wir auf
beiden seiten noch defizite in der
umsetzung habe und das liegt ganz
einfach daran dass es einen streit
darüber gibt in welcher reihenfolge man
das umsetzen muss also wenn wir uns
anschauen wie es ein minus gab kommen
besteht und wie es ja auch das muss man
ganz klar sagen in dem moment
abgeschlossen wurde in der die ukraine
militärische oder schlechter tanz ist
das so zuerst waren vereinbart wurden in
nebra touristengebieten darauf aufbauend
die errichtung eines autonomiestatus
oder die festlegung eines
autonomiestatus für den bombast und erst
im anschluss sollte die ukraine wieder
die volle kontrolle über die grenze
erlagen das problem dann ist natürlich
dass wenn sie erst danach die grenze
schießen oder ukrainische kontrolle
herstellen dass russland dann sehr sehr
große möglichkeiten hat die dabei ein so
beeinflussen jetzt dass john bass und
ist als autonomiestatus ein hebel zu
kriegen über die hier war politik und
das möchte ich natürlich verhindern
haben und fordert den gesprächen dass er
die grenze wieder unter ukrainische
kontrolle gestellt wird und das team aus
der knackpunkt das haben wir heute nach
der pressekonferenz von bundeskanzler
scholz und dem russischen präsidenten
putin von beiden seiten zumindest die
nach wie vor die gesprächsbereitschaft
gehört wie geht das jetzt ihrer meinung
wie geht es weiter in den nächsten tagen
hoffentlich nicht wochen aber ja was
sehen sie
ja ich denke dass wir schon nach rechnen
müssen dass selbst wenn es zu keinem
krieg kommt uns das mehrere wochen
beschäftigen wird alles eben nicht das
was man im handumdrehen lösen kann also
ganz deutlich es ist ja so dass
erreicht hat dass diese gesetze die die
grundlage sind für die wahlen für den
autonomiestatus umkehr verarbeitet
werden und dass man das dann im rahmen
des moment die form artest mit russland
mit moskau bespricht und dann wird man
sehen müssen was man genau dieses
dilemma des zeitlichen ablauf ist das
ist sehr gut über kommen also über
gelder kommen kann
vielen dank zara packung von der
deutschen gesellschaft für auswärtige
politik dankeschön und
auch dank an euch für die aufmerksamkeit
entschuldigung für jetzt eben den nicht
so besonders guten ton am ende das
passiert leider manchmal gerade wenn man
so schnell live geht wie wir das tun das
machen wir natürlich auch jetzt in den
nächsten tagen wieder für euch wann
immer was passiert sind wir da und bis
dahin tschüss